the Strategic arms reduction treaty
first signed by presidents Bush and
Gorbachev in 1991 has been part of the
nuclear weapons framework in some form
ever since Barack Obama and Dmitry
Medvedev inaugurated its successor new
start in 2010 under its terms Russia and
the United States owners of 90 percent
of the world's nuclear weapons would
limit their deployed strategic Warheads
to
1550 and their long-range missiles and
bombers to 700 each side could inspect
the other sites to ensure compliance up
to 18 times a year
but inspections were halted first by
covid-19 and then by deteriorating
relations since Russia's invasion of
Ukraine on Tuesday in Moscow Vladimir
Putin announced Russia was suspending
its membership he said in response to
hostile U.S actions
and now they want to inspect our defense
objects in the current condition of
Confrontation that takes place today it
sounds like nonsense U.S Russia
relations on nuclear weapons have been
strained for years the United States
pulled out of the anti-ballistic missile
treaty in 2002 and let the intermediate
range nuclear forces treaty in 2019
accusing Russia of developing a cruise
missile that breached its terms
experts fear a breakdown of the
architecture that for decades has
reigned in nuclear arsenals we seem to
be losing the last bilateral
relationship governing nuclear weapons
so he could have an arms race after this
and that arms race has not existed
because of this agreement because of the
inspections that back up the
intelligence that both states have and
so you have one of those pillars being
taken away Joe Biden agreed a five-year
extension to new start when he took
office in 2021 Vladimir Putin emphasized
his action was a suspension not a
withdrawal but has raised the prospect
of the treaty lapsing in 2026. he also
said he had put new nuclear systems on
combat Duty and pledged to resume
nuclear testing if the United States did
the same Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera